will become the greatest swordsman in  the world this green-haired first Maid  of the straw hat Pirates grew up in  shimotsky Village a small samurai colony  in the East blue it was in the dojo  there where he learned swordsmanship and  fought against his rival and dear  childhood friend kuina however after  queena's tragic untimely death the  heartbroken Zorro swore that he would  carry on her dream to become the  greatest swordsman Zoro invented The  Impossible looking three sword style and  joined Straw Hat Luffy after the pirate  rescued him from execution by the  Marines helmeppo and his father accent  Morgan shortly after when encountering  the currently strongest swordsman and  warlord of the sea mihawk he suffered a  bitter and almost deadly defeat but  swore to his captain that he would never  lose again since then he has been the  most reliable member of the crew  supporting Luffy through all of the  challenges they face together and when  he finally defeats dracul mihawk